Niger quarter,
Lisa,
who was like,
they looked really similar.
They shared a fake Id.
They were like sisters.
And one day when they were in the late teens,
they went to ocean city for day out and Lisa decided to hitchhike back to New
Jersey where she lived.
And uh,
so Lisa bye to her and the next day she gets a call saying Lisa had not arrived.
So she waits and waits.
She has this terrible summer waiting to find out what happened.
And then they discovered that Lisa had been gang raped and murdered.
Her body was found underneath a house where it had been eaten by animals.
Um,
and Lee becomes,
became convinced at that time that,
that Lisa had for spares reasons that Lisa had been killed as part of a gang
initiation ceremony.
She like,
she's like,
I'm going to destroy these gangs,
going to dedicate my life to destroying these gangs.
She goes and applies to become a police officer and for years she's this,
you know,
hardline cop,
right?
It takes real pleasure in busting people.
But Lee started to notice a few things.
First thing was when you're a cop and you arrest a rapist,
there are fewer rapes in your town the next week,
right?
When you are a cop and you bust a pedophile,
fewer children get sexually abused.
But she knows when you dropped buster dealer,
there's no fewer dealers.
There's someone on the corner of the next day for sure.
Right?
It didn't seem to be having any effect.
In fact,
what she discovered,
what she was,
she began to learn about this was that there was something,
uh,
even worse,
which was,
um,
it for funny sort of reason that she realized that she was actually creating
these empowering these gangs.
So the best way to explain this is if you imagine,
obviously when you,
when you ban drugs,
they don't disappear,
right?
That transfer from the people who are used to control them,
licensed legal businesses to armed criminal gangs,
right?
And these aren't criminal gangs operate in a different way to,
to legal businesses.
So if you imagined,
if you and me decided we want to go and steal now a bottle of vodka,
right?
We go into local liquor store and that store catches us,
they'll call the cops.
The cops would come and take us away.
That liquor store doesn't need to be violent.
It doesn't need to be intimidating.
They've got the power of the law to uphold their property rights.
Can now imagine we were to steal a bag of coke,
right?
If we go to the guy near here,
I'm sure there is someone who,
who,
um,
sells coke.
Um,
and he catches us.
He can't call the cops.
Obviously cops would arrest him.
He has to fight us.
Now,
if you're a dealer,
you don't want to be having a fight every day,
right?
You want to establish a reputation for being so frightening that no one would
dare to fuck with you,
right?
So you,
you establish your place in that neighborhood through aggression,
through violence,
and you maintain it through aggression and violence,
right?
Uh,
legal businesses compete on cost and quality of product.
in illegal markets.
People compete on how much of a frightening fucker you're prepared to be,
right?
And as a writer called Carlsbad and put it,
um,
the war on drugs creates a wall for drugs,
right?
It transfers it to these criminal gangs who have to operate through violence to
protect their property rights.
So lingos into the drug war thinking I'm the one stopping these gangs.
She realizes she,
I'm the one enabling them,
right?
They control one of the biggest industries in the world because of this police
sanction.
And because of this decision to prohibit these drugs.
And if you want to know how much of this violence is caused by,
by,
um,
by the fact that we prohibited it,
just ask yourself,
where are the violent alcohol dealers?
Right?
Everyone knows who al Capone was.
Does the head of Smirnoff go and shoot the head of Budweiser in the face?
Right?
Does your local bar go and sell a bunch of kids to go and shoot everyone in the
next bar down?
Of course not exactly.
That happened at the alcohol prohibition.
When did it end ended on the day alcohol prohibition ended.
Cause legal markets don't compete with that.
So at least partly having this insight,
right?
She's realizing,
Shit,
I think I'm taking down these gangs.
I'm actually empowering them.
What will really disempowered them as reclaiming the market and making it legal,
but she also has another really painful realization.
So early in her career as a cop,
Lee had done this really brief thing.
She'd gone undercover with the clan to expose them.
She'd done a really important work and breaking up parts of the Maryland clam.
She really was not a racist,
right?
She'd had relationships with African American men,
but she knows something that most honest cops notice,
which is the vast majority of people,
the,
they were sent to African American areas to enforce the drug laws.
Right.
One of our colleagues,
Matthew fog,
once went to his superior officer and said,
you know,
this is a bit weird,
right?
We only ever seem to go to African American neighborhoods to do all our drug
busts.
I'm fairly sure white people sometimes use drug.
Should we go to like a white neighborhood as well?
And the supervisor said,
of course you're right.
White people use drugs,
but white people,
no journalists and lawyers and judges.
That's really,
we just get a whole load of shit for us.
Just go for the low hanging fruit.
So Lee who is not a racist,
could see the effect of what she was doing was in fact racist.
Right.
And she was very uncomfortable with that.
And this really came to a head Billy when leaves police partner was guy called
ed totally.
Who she loved.
Platonically loved.
Um,
yeah,
he was a great champion of women police officers.
It was a great guy.
And one day she gets a call at home.
Ed had been sent on a drug bust.
He was undercover and the guy had thought it was ripping them off and shot him
in the head.
And Lee goes to see eds body and she's like,
what did he die for?
Right?
There are no fewer drug dealers.
Every time we arrest the drug dealer,
the supply of drugs is not disrupted for one hour.
We are enforcing a racist war.
We are empowering these gangs.
Why are we doing this?
So Lee quit as a police officer,
she retrained as a lawyer.
She now gets the criminal records expunged wherever she can have the kind of
people that she busted when she was a cop and she's a big,
she was part of a brilliant group called law enforcement against prohibition who
are cops who argue for,
for ending the drug war.
But it's interesting to me because it's hard to be Harry Lee was trying to be
Harry Anslinger is hard to be Harry Anslinger if you're an honest person with a
conscience.
Right?
And there are police officers all over the country who are making these,
these,
these realizations now and that,
you know,
obviously it's very close to my heart what we do to people with addiction
problems.
But I don't,
horrific and catastrophic though.
That is,
I don't actually think that's the biggest moral issue around the war on drugs.
The biggest moral issue is the violence created by prohibition.
Right?
If I think about places I've spent time like Columbia,
um,
see that Horez in northern Mexico,
that's the biggest issue,
right?
More people have died in,
in Latin America,
central and South America,
in the drug war,
violence than have died in Syria.
I don't know what we can do about Syria.
We can end this violence.
There's professor at Harvard called Jeffrey Myron [inaudible] trying to be too,
he has a graph of the murder rate in the 20th century in the United States,
massively shoots up the day alcohol is banned and falls like a stone.
The day alcohol is legalized,
right?
And massively rises again when this an intensification of the drug war later.
And we can end a huge amount of this violence,
right?
We can do what Switzerland did,
we can do what?
What's happening here man?
What's stopping us?
So I think the main thing this is,
cause this is a lot
go conclusion based on facts and based on cases like Portugal and Switzerland,
there's obviously data.
So people are aware of this.
So people must be confronted with this data.
To this day,
people know that the prohibition on alcohol was a massive disaster and no one
would ever accept it again.
We're slowly starting to realize that marijuana,
at least for some people is,
is safe and reasonable and should be used recreationally and has some massive
benefits medically.
So we're starting to see legalization both for recreational use and,
uh,
clearly for medical use spread.
I think,
what did we decide what it was?
It,
I think it's like there's a certain amount of states where it's just fully legal
recreationally and more where it's medical,
but I think it's more than 18 states total.
As soon we're going to be half of the American population,
90%.
I mean,
we all is in Canada
and it should be,
yes it is in Canada as it should be for alcohol.
But what,
what is the stop?
What is the wall between this and legalization of all these other drugs and
counseling and implementing some sort of a Switzerland like pro
Graham?
I think onto the really important question.
So there's a range of things.
Um,
this is a public perception of big one.
I think you've gone to the most important,
right?
So some people say it's the vested financial interest in the existing system.
That's true.
If you look at who funds the no campaigns,
whenever they want to legalize marijuana,
you can see the interest,
right?
Prison guard unions,
um,
alcohol companies cause they didn't want a commercial competitor.
Um,
religious fundamentalist groups like Mormons,
not the all Mormons fundamentalist,
but the groups,
the funding this are,
um,
so it's partly that,
but I think you're right.
I don't think that's the main thing that's going on.
It's,
it's significant and real,
but it's the main thing that's going on.
The main thing,
the main block is
huge.
Majorities of Americans more than 80% say the war on drugs has failed and been a
disaster.
And yet most people are afraid of the alternatives.
Right?
And that's pot setting as two things going on.
There's ignorance about what the alternatives actually mean.
So re one of the reasons why chasing the scream is written as I went to all
these places from the killing fields in northern Mexico to Switzerland is
because way too often in this debate,
we talk like we're a philosophy seminar.
People go,
well,
what would legalization mean?
How would it work?
And they go to this weird abstract conversation like,
fuck that.
Here's a plane ticket to Geneva.
Here's a plane ticket to Lisbon is a plane ticket to Colorado,
right?
It's not rocket science,
I've been to the places that I've tried these things,
we can see the results,
right?
Then they're not legalization is not an APP or decrement and decolonization.
I can explain the difference if you want,
are not abstract,
are the,
what's the key differences between legalization and decriminalization?
Decriminalization is where you stop punishing users,
but they still have to go to arm criminal gangs to get their drug.
Legalization is where you open up some legal route for people to get their
drugs.
And that's varies according to the drug,
right?
So I guess the kind of headline would be decriminalization shuts down.
Orange is the new black and legalization shuts down breaking bad and Naacos.
Right.
And of course we need to do both.
Threatening to decriminalize use and legalized supplies.